[Music]
it had all the comforts of home the
ukrainian flag the national anthem and
cossack dancers wearing embroidered
shirts but this celebration is 12 000
kilometers away from kiev in the small
brazilian town of prudentopolis
a feast to welcome 63 ukrainian refugees
we wanted to show them that they can
feel at home here prudentopolis is
brazil's little ukraine pastor vitalia
moved from ukraine to prudentopolis four
years ago only to discover that almost
every corner of his new home reminded
him of his old one from the architecture
to the bible in cyrillic and the
catholic mass held in his native tongue
three-quarters of the 53 000 people
living in prudentopolis still speak
ukrainian and maintain the traditions of
their ancestors who started migrating to
brazil as early as the 1800s
i remember my father in the 1940s taking
in a couple who had fled the second
world war and i said it was the hustle
now prudentopolis is preparing for the
new wave of ukrainians fleeing from the
russian invasion
they were brought over by global kingdom
a worldwide network of churches who
promote humanitarian causes
we started preparing to take in refugees
last year after seeing the shocking
images of people hanging onto a plane
trying to escape the taliban regime in
afghanistan we did the paperwork to
bring afghan families over but by the
time they were able to reach brazil the
russian invasion of ukraine had started
we moved rapidly to bring the ukrainian
refugees on board
eleven ukrainian families were taken to
guara puava a city just 80 kilometers
from prudentopolis they were housed in
separate apartments in the same building
olga martinchok fled with her husband
and children from her son family was
traveling to poland when they received a
message that brazil was taking in
refugees
we heard about brazilian carnivals and
we heard about beaches here we heard
about amazonia and
forests and that it is a green country
and
beautiful people
actually we didn't know much
27 of the 36 ukrainian refugees living
here in guarapuava are children and
they're already studying in brazilian
schools like this one
alga's son emmanuel is in the same
classroom as another young refugee
when the teacher has trouble
communicating with children she uses her
phone as a translator
olga has no immediate plans for the
future her house in herasan is now being
occupied by russian troops
back in prudentopolis brazilians and
ukrainians are praying for the war to
end before that manika yanaki of al
jazeera prudentopolis
[Music]